[Music]
hello this is sky news today it's one
o'clock these are our headlines the
ukrainian city of kharkiv comes under
attack as the interior minister says
dozens are killed in rocket strikes
there
russian nuclear forces are put on
enhanced combat duty despite peace talks
beginning on the ukrainian belarusian
border
the human face of war polina and her
parents among more than 100 civilians
killed so far in the conflict
between thursday morning and last night
our office has recorded 406 billion
casualties including 102 killed
including seven children and 304 injured
more than half a million people have now
crossed the border from ukraine to
escape the fighting
the russian ruble falls to an all-time
low as britain sanctions russia's
central bank
whilst the average uk petrol prices hit
another record high
[Music]
hello good afternoon a ukrainian
official has said this lunchtime that
dozens of people have been killed in
rocket strikes on the country's second
city kharkiv
delegations from ukraine and russia are
currently sitting down for talks after a
weekend of soaring tensions
despite that in the last few minutes
russia's interfax news agency has
reported that russia's nuclear forces
have been placed on enhanced combat duty
in line with an order over the weekend
from the country's president vladimir
putin
meanwhile the united nations says it's
recorded more than 100 civilian deaths
including seven children and more than
300 people injured since russia began
its attack on ukraine last week
security and defense editor deborah
haynes is in kiev and deborah what are
we able to glean about what is happening
in kharkiv
well it seems that that city it's
ukraine's second largest city in the
east of the country uh has been
subjected to a heavy bombardment of of
rocket fire and like you said the
interior ministry is putting the
casualty toll that dozens dead hundreds
wounded we wait to see what the final uh
confirmation is on those figures but the
images that you can see you can see now
on your screen the sound of uh of that
heavy strikes the smoke rising up um it
looks incredible a punishing um
onslaught onto the city by russian
forces russian forces who let's not
forget have yet to take a major city in
day five of this invasion clearly not
going to plan
in terms of the advances they had been
expecting and that city kharkiv is is
significant for russia's operation they
were battling in the streets with
ukrainian forces yesterday uh trying to
seize control but the ukrainians saying
uh towards the end of the day that they
that ukraine remained uh in control of
the city and so it would seem and this
is in line with what western officials
have previously suggested might happen
that when the russian military fails to
make the advances it had hoped to make
um just using its more conventional
firepower it would escalate the violence
um use a greater volume of um
of strikes onto a target which does seem
to be the case uh in terms of what we're
seeing in kharkiv and it's important as
well to remember that that onslaught has
happened as these talks are underway um
between ukrainian and russian officials
um up on the ukraine belarus border the
first talk since this conflict began and
also as this capital city kiev where i'm
standing um remains as well on
heightened alert with
russian forces still not penetrating
overtly into the city but there have
been clashes in the streets we've heard
gunfire not so far i must i must admit
uh in the last few hours but there are
still air raid sirens and there have
been explosions and attacks uh missile
strikes on apartment buildings
terrifying for people who have been
forced to shelter in in metro stations
and underground basements and just to
give you a final sense of the the human
impact of this conflict um i was taken
today as part of a media trip we were
taken to the main children's hospital
here in kiev and it's a hospital which
has got high-tech facilities to help the
sickest children the poorliest little
ones they're the children who are
suffering from illnesses like leukemia
and children who need dialysis and the
doctors there looked exhausted and they
said to me that they have two big
challenges first of all how to look
after very sick children in a war zone
where there's explosions outside
artillery fire he said as well at one
doctor outside they had to take the
children into the basement and then also
dealing with children impacted by the
war they said they've had three
casualties so far of children
okay thanks very much deborah well let's
take a look at today's other
developments the united nations refugee
agency says more than half a million
people have now fled ukraine into
neighboring countries
the ukrainian delegation is currently at
the border with belarus for talks with
russian representatives
ukrainian presidency says they'll work
on achieving an immediate ceasefire and
the withdrawal of russian forces
russian currency the ruble has sunk to
an all-time low following tough
sanctions imposed on the country
russia's central bank has raised
interest rates to 20 percent in a bid to
combat rising inflation and shore up the
currency
and a spokesperson for the russian
billionaire roman abramovich who owns
the premier league club chelsea say that
he has accepted a ukrainian request to
help negotiate an end to the conflict
well coming up we'll hear from our
correspondents in moscow washington
brussels and on the polish border with
ukraine where thousands of refugees are
continuing to cross
but first these are the latest pictures
of those talks taking place at the
border with belarus
dear friends
president of belarus
asked
me to meet you
to welcome you and to ensure the comfort
of your work
and as
uh you can feel completely safe here
this is our duty president lukashanka
sincerely hopes
that
in the course of today's negotiations
you'll be able to resolve everything
and all
people of belarus
pray for this
and we are waiting for the results
well a short time ago ukraine's
president zielenski made an address and
called on the eu to admit ukraine under
a new special procedure
muy
we asked the european union to admit
ukraine immediately under a new special
procedure we are grateful to our
partners for fighting with us but our
goal is to be together with all
europeans and the main thing to be on
equal terms i'm convinced that this is
just i am certain that we have earned
this i am certain that all this is
possible
well our international affairs editor
dominic wagon joins us now from moscow
and dominic we've heard again from
president putin in the last hour on
state tv
yeah we have just to update you on those
talks so um the word we're getting from
kiev from the ukrainian uh president's
office being quoted by ukrainian media
is saying we now know what the ukrainian
delegation those talks with the russians
have been asking for they have used
those talks the beginning of those talks
to demand the removal of russian forces
uh from ukraine but also from donbass
and from crimea so a um a pretty
assertive start to ukraine's um opening
salvos at those negotiations yes but as
you say vladimir putin has been lashing
out this morning um in um comments uh
relayed by his spokesperson dmitry
peskov in the kremlin he is referred to
the west as an empire of lies uh
following these sanctions that have been
imposed on his country and he's also
been talking about the reasons why he
put his nuclear deterrence forces so
nuclear missiles on increased readiness
something he's now stepped up to combat
readiness it's been reported in the last
hour or so now he is blaming that
directly on or his spokesperson is
directly on comments made by liz truss
uh suggesting that nato might be on a
collision course with russia and a bit
more has come out of um that since the
uh the quote is saying that uh in the
opinion of british foreign secretary liz
truss the ukraine situation might
eventually develop into a conflict uh
with nato unless the actions of russia
were stopped and that is most likely
referring to comments that the foreign
secretary made to trevor phillips on sky
news over the weekend
when
she said this if we don't stop putin in
ukraine we are going to see others
under threat the baltics poland moldova
and it could end up in a conflict with
nato so what the kremlin is saying is
that vladimir putin or his aides were
listening to those words felt that that
could be um pointing to the possibility
of conflict between nato and russia and
that's why he put his nuclear missiles
on increased readiness
okay dominic thank you
well the un's secretary general has
warned that the escalation of russia's
military operations in ukraine is
leading to rising human rights
violations in the country during a
recorded speech at the opening of the
human rights council in geneva antonio
guterres said that the un was monitoring
the situation and they would support
people on the ground
the escalation of military operations by
the russian federation ukraine
is leading to escalating human rights
violations
we know the inevitable result of war
civilian casualties women children and
men forced from their homes hunger
poverty and huge economic disruption
conflict is the utter negation of human
rights across the board
freedom of expression is under attack
with reports of journalists and
activists arrested
i have consistently called for the end
of the offensive and the return to the
paths of dialogue and diplomacy
meanwhile our human rights monitoring
mission in ukraine is continuing its
work and our humanitarian agencies will
step up their operations
we must show all people in ukraine that
we stand by them in their time of need
disguise laura bundock joins me now from
brussels laura what help is the eu able
to offer
well that's what's been discussed
recently in terms of the humanitarian
side of things um they're obviously
expecting and already seeing thousands
and thousands of ukrainian refugees
crossing into bordering countries so far
the u.n estimates over half a million
have now made that journey arriving in
countries like poland hungary and
romania laura apologies there's an issue
clearly with the sound on your
microphone so we're going to come away
from that and we'll try and return to
laura in a short while
in the meantime in the last hour the
united states has announced that it's
expanding sanctions against russia's
central bank freezing its assets in the
u.s and banning any americans from doing
business with it so let's go to
washington and sky's sally lockwood
there so a further tranche of measures
sally
yeah we were warned over the weekend
that the u.s and its western allies were
planning more measures and around half
seven
uh this morning a little over half an
hour ago the treasury did announce
further punitive measures against russia
already the white house tweeting in the
last 20 minutes
that the u.s along with its allies are
preventing putin from accessing his war
chest with new measures of course that
announcement from the treasury
of more sanctions on russia's central
bank which will ban americans from doing
any business with the bank and freezing
any assets
it holds in america on top of that the
us is also adding
another putin ally to the sanctions list
that of course on top of the already uh
deep sanctions announced by president
biden last week and that decision to
remove several russian banks from the
swift interbank messaging system over
the weekend one of the most drastic
measures that the west could impose on
russia in terms of punishing it
financially but another announcement
we've also had from secretary of state
anthony blinken already this morning
that america will suspend its operations
at its embassy in belarus in miss in
minsk with immediate effect and it's
authorized the voluntary departure of
non-emergency staff and family members
from its embassy in moscow uh that
announcement as well in the last hour
certainly america uh is keeping its
focus on sanctions when it comes to
dealing with putin and perhaps a
strategic silence as well from president
biden over the weekend after that rather
shocking announcement from the russian
president that he was going to put his
nuclear forces
on high alert now joe biden
had two options he could have either
responded and done the same or chosen to
ignore president putin which is what has
happened so far joe biden choosing
instead to de-escalate but it has led to
a response from the un security council
who voted to hold a very rare special
session which will begin
in just under two hours from now ahead
of a vote on a resolution expected on
wednesday on russia's
behavior and decision to invade
ukraine now this is only the 11th time
since 1950 that the u.n general assembly
has held such
an emergency session
now that will come ahead of that vote on
wednesday which will criticize russia
and and call for this war to end now of
course this is just words uh will putin
care will he listen well it's really of
course just designed to further isolate
uh vladimir putin on the world stage but
of course that announcement for him uh
over the weekend from him putting his
nuclear forces on high alert is of
course in the forefront
of american security officials minds
over this side of the atlantic of course
all too aware of how this situation
could escalate into a direct standoff
between superpowers
okay sally thank you very much a little
bit more information coming out of
russia in the last few moments there
have been a number of air bans uh that
the russian authorities had put on
various countries in retaliation
for those countries banning their
airlines this has now been extended to
36 countries uh russia's banned airlines
from 36 countries including britain
germany spain italy and canada from
using russian airspace in their
retaliatory move
now the un says more than 400 000
ukrainians have fled their homeland and
the eu has braced for millions more to
enter the block let's talk now to our
europe correspondent adam parsons joins
us now from the polish border with
ukraine they are still continuing to
stream across aren't they adam what's
the latest
yeah the the guess is that about maybe
half a million people have already left
ukraine and more than half of them
already going for 300 000 have come here
uh to poland there's a good example have
a look at uh this this is what we're
seeing a lot of
uh you see here lots of women and
children and in the heart of this a big
pile of their
personal possessions these people have
come in on a on a bus just crossing
the border
this morning and like so many others
they've come to this processing center
the system is you come across the border
often after an incredibly arduous
journey and we hear people telling us uh
spending days getting to the border you
come to this
processing center now we were here
yesterday and i have told you that the
whole mood of this place has changed
quite subtly because yesterday there was
a lot of good will
around this place plenty of people
arriving from ukraine and they had
places to go to they had family members
meeting them it feels today as if this
is turning rapidly much more into the
sort of refugee processing facility
that you might get in
calais or orland producers in
far more people who are milling around
who don't seem to have a plan of where
to go to and i have to say we can't take
you inside here but this is because
we're an astronaut to film in there
people who own this building don't want
us going in there
but in there
there are hundreds of people who are
using camp beds and lots and lots of
them are men and we didn't see so much
of that uh yesterday
and almost all of them are non-ukrainian
so i was in there half an hour or so ago
there's a queue of maybe 60 70 people
queuing up to try and get some some
temporary papers and i spoke to to a few
of them there were some some people
there from uzbekistan from mongolia i
spoke to a man who had come from india
he'd been a chef in a restaurant in
odessa and he said he'd left when he
heard explosions and he then said uh
that he got as new as he could to the
border the city of la viv just near the
border and had then got stuck in an
enormous traffic jam and had walked and
he estimated he'd walked
about
30 kilometers in order to get toward
that so he
like a lot of people
here was absolutely
exhausted
now paulin has said it will take in
all ukrainians but it will look after
them
that it will give them
housing and education it will give them
shelter but make no mistake that this
process is turning quickly from simply
welcoming these people to now poland and
i think the eu is having to think in
reality how do you accommodate a
humanitarian crisis that is developing
unfolding and growing before our eyes
adam thanks very much
well the russian ruble has fallen to a
record low today after sanctions against
russia were tightened still further our
business presenter ian king joins me now
from the city uh what's going on in
russia and their banks
well uh jane the move over the weekend
in which uh the west sought to sanction
russia's central bank is by far the
biggest stick yet wielded we were
talking last week of course about
cutting russian banks out to swift the
global interbank messaging service that
facilitates cross-border payments now
that in itself is pretty damaging in
that it hinders the ability of russian
banks to make payments or collect
payments across board on behalf of their
clients but this is far bigger still
because it effectively prevents russia
from getting its hands on a large part
of the 643 billion dollar
cushion that it's built up over recent
years to protect itself against the
impact of sanctions so potentially that
is a move that could precipitate a
financial crisis in russia it will
certainly lead potentially to more
inflation and shortages of goods and
accordingly as you say the ruble has
fallen very sharply at one point it was
down by 29
against the us dollar it's actually
recovered a bit uh some mourning has
gone on it's only about 17 off on the
course of the day it's down some 65
percent against the dollar over the last
five years the russian central bank has
responded by raising its main policy
rate interest rates they've gone up from
nine and a half percent to 20 today and
in the last few minutes jane the central
bank governor in russia elvira nabilena
she has been stating the reasons why the
central bank acted in the way that it
could she said that it was important to
see off inflation compensate citizens
against the damage that inflation would
do to their savings she stressed that
all funds held in russian banks are safe
that's very much a message for domestic
consumption and she's also said that the
bank has made efforts that will prevent
russian banks from having to make
provisions against potential bad debts
which she says is worth some 900 billion
euros that's worth around 90 billion us
dollars as things stand and she's also
pointed out very interestingly that
russia has its own internal uh payments
messaging system called fpfs it's a
system that uh is modeled on swift and
she said if anyone wants to carry on
making or receiving payments from
russian entities they can do so via that
service as well so that's the latest the
oil price by the way currently up just
above 100 per barrel
okay ian thank you very much
well a half past three today the foreign
secretary liz trust is going to address
the comments on the latest sanctions
against russia we will bring that to you
live here on sky news
and if you scan the qr code on your
screen right now you can listen to the
latest edition of the sky news daily
podcast today kate mccann is looking at
how misinformation is weaponized in war
and how journalists work to verify what
is real and what isn't you can subscribe
to the daily wherever you get your
podcasts
this is sky news today coming up why the
russian advance in ukraine over the last
five days appears to have been slower
than expected
[Music]
[Music]
please just make their first move and
they're bothering firing together
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
there are hundreds of these turbines but
thousands more across gansu
[Music]
that's what's left of the north tunnel
where the north koreans exploded five
nuclear warheads
[Music]
and this is a show of strength at a time
when china is more fragile than it has
been at any time in recent years
we take you to the heart of the stories
that shape our world
the train station the airport they're
both closed we're not sure about the
roads we've seen reports that they are
being blocked by police so we're going
to try and find a way out of wuhan
after five days stranded here this is
deliverance we help you understand the
world with us
tom cheshire sky news beijing
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
now it's day five of the russian
invasion in ukraine but the russian
advance has been slower than expected
let's get more now from the defense and
security analyst michael clark on why
that is um so michael first of all how
far have the russian forces advanced
well um when we started this process in
on thursday jane we expected these
arrows to become pretty long and very
with curls on them as they encircled
their objectives but they haven't got
very far the fact is the russian advance
has stalled in most places the places
where they've made some progress is down
in the south uh butyansk has fallen to
russian forces that's the first
strategic objective they've really made
but maria paul right down there which
should have fallen within hours is still
fighting after five days we don't really
know what's going on in mario paul but
there must be some sort of alamo playing
itself out there so very difficult kiev
of course is the center and and what
about kiev itself um
we know that there are our troops on
their way to kiev
what's the latest on those well we know
that russian troops have arrived in
northern and west of kiev
one of the major armored thrusts from
belarus has got there but the other
thrust coming from russia from the
northeast has not made it they've been
held up and they held up after five days
a major uh battle went on for hostimel
airfield the russians tried to take it
with an air assault was beaten back as
far as we know the ukrainians still hold
it and that's critical of course because
if the russians had an airfield to work
with they could actually attack kiev
much more easily they don't seem to have
got that so they do have some real
problems because their
lines of communication are now quite
long they're being attacked on their
lines of communications but
the ukrainians are fighting with
everything they've got they can't fight
forever the russians can keep bringing
fresh troops in and there are reports
today that fresh russian troops are
moving to the belarusian border they
might well send them down the column
that they have got open to try to
encircle kiev in the near future so it
does seem that the russian advances has
stalled where does that leave president
putin in terms of options
at least president putin having to
choose what sort of weapons to use i
mean we've had this footage in of what
looked like a pattern of cluster
munition explosions in kharkiv um these
sorts of weapons are devastating in
civilian areas not to mention illegal
president putin may have to decide how
brutal he is prepared to be
in this case the ukrainians are saying
we're going to peace talks in belarus
we'll talk as if we are not fighting and
we'll fight as if we're not talking but
president putin seems to be facing the
choice as to whether he goes negotiating
or goes brutal and i guess he hasn't
really had to face that choice for a
very long time
okay michael thanks very much really
interesting analysis um let's just bring
you some breaking news out of downing
street let's cross live to westminster
and our chief political correspondent
john craig the prime minister is
stepping up his diplomatic efforts as
well as all the sanctions and military
aid for ukraine number 10 has just
announced that the prime minister will
travel to estonia and poland tomorrow uh
for meetings with his counterparts and
the nato secretary journal
general um the prime minister has been
making it very clear we are told that we
do not want to unnecessarily inflict
damage on the russian people many of
whom are bravely taking to the streets
to protest this violence this invasion
but the measures we're introducing in
large parts of the world are introducing
are to bring down the putin regime now
they say they're not seeking regime
change
talking about how they stop russia
seeking to subjugate a democratic
country now the pm is going to speak to
the polish president this afternoon
ahead of his visit cabinet has met this
morning the prime minister told his
colleagues it's becoming clearer with
each day that president putin has made a
colossal mistake believing the guns of
his tanks would be garlanded with roses
and when instead the ukrainian people
have put up a fierce resistance in
defense of their homeland
mr johnson said the latest intelligence
suggested putin's advances had been
hampered by logistical problems and the
heroic efforts of the ukrainian military
who were inflicting significant
casualties on the russian troops uh he
also said this is the prime minister
telling talking to the cabinet that
president putin had underestimated
western unity uh went on to talk about
the ruble falling inflation uh on the uh
three move three that the government is
acting in three main areas economically
diplomatically and militarily on the
economic front the uk is going to
continue to lead efforts to go further
calling for russia to be cut out of
swift completely that's a step further
than is happening so far
he said further sanctions on russian
businesses will be introduced shortly
and uh the aim is to prevent the
uh the chancellor's announced the
unprecedented step of preventing the
central bank of the russian federation
from deploying foreign reserves finally
militarily uh the uk decision to provide
defensive military military capability
to ukraine early on had been vindicated
and
also there's more news to come according
to number 10 on visas on russia today
the government says politicians don't
decide what uh
media able to broadcast that's for ofcom
um and uh on sanctions we believe that
the sanctions are having an impact
there'll be a further update uh from liz
trust the foreign secretary in the house
of commons on um uh 3 30 this afternoon
uh the other development this afternoon
is at the pm speaking to his the polish
president ahead of a trip this is boris
johnson going to estonia and poland
tomorrow for meeting with his
counterparts and the nato secretary
general
thanks very much
you're watching sky news a day after
handing over stewardship of chelsea it's
been revealed that roman abramovich is
involved in the peace talks between
russia and ukraine
[Music]
so
[Music]
welcome back to our continuing coverage
of russia's invasion of ukraine well
just a day after handing over
stewardship of chelsea it's been
revealed that the football club's owner
roman abramovich is involved in the
peace talks between russia and ukraine
our sports correspondent tom parmenter
is live at chelsea's stadium stamford
bridge what's this all about tom
well from the pictures that we've seen
so far from those meetings that have
been happening on the border between
belarus and ukraine it's not immediately
apparent that roman abramovich is there
but we are certainly told that he has
been involved in the process
of those talks and is being something of
a conduit between the two sides we
understand that the contact came through
a ukrainian film producer called
alexander
rodianski and they were effectively
trying to find someone on the russian
side or with deep russian connections
who would be able to facilitate these
talks and try to act as a bridge and mr
abramovich is the one who has
volunteered to do that a spokesman for
the chelsea owner has said i can confirm
that roman abramovich was contacted by
the ukrainian side for support in
achieving a peaceful resolution and that
he has been trying to help ever since
considering what is at stake we would
ask for your understanding as to why we
have not commented on either the
situation as such
nor his involvement and it comes just a
day or two after he stepped back from
the
ownership of or from the stewardship
certainly of the club not the ownership
yet but he has certainly moved his
attention away from running chelsea this
is the man of course who has ushered in
the most successful period the club has
ever known but his focus is very much
now on trying to help and do what he can
and the ukrainian side have admitted
that his role and capabilities may be
limited but he is there as a willing
participant trying to broker a peace
deal so one of the more surprising
developments today on the international
side of the football
connection to this story and the
maneuvers that have been happening
against russian teams we know that the
english fa have been confirming to our
colleagues at sky sports news today that
they have expressed their request to
fifa that the russian men's team is
kicked out of the world cup and also
that the russian women's team is not
allowed to take part in the
euros that are due to take place in the
summer so a lot happening within the
world of sport connected to the crisis
in ukraine and roman abramovich perhaps
an unlikely figure but certainly someone
who is directly now involved in those
talks that have been ongoing and we will
wait to see exactly what influence he
can bring to bear in what is a very
grave situation
okay tom thank you very much
some breaking news now one of britain's
biggest fund managers has been left
unable to sell its shareholding in the
russian state oil giant amid
restrictions on foreign share trades on
moscow's stock exchange let's cross live
to london and our city editor mark
kleinman mark tell us more yeah that's
right jane it's just an interesting
development on the news that we had over
the weekend about bp's plan to sell its
huge shareholding in rosneft the russian
state oil giant now i understand that a
number of uk-based fund managers have
been trying to offload their own
positions in this uh russian
state-backed company but have been
unable to do so because of restrictions
that have been placed on foreign share
trades on the moscow stock exchange now
this fund manager in particular aberdeen
holds a relatively modest uh stake in
rosneft it's worth just five million
pounds but it decided to sell these
shares as soon as russia's invasion of
ukraine uh took place and it's been left
holding
that position uh and there's no clue as
to when and if it may
be able to get rid of it in the near
term it's just an interesting example of
how the crisis in
ukraine is manifesting itself in the
city of london in unexpected ways a
number of other fund managers in the
city are also keen to sell their
positions in rosneft but are in the same
situation as aberdeen we may hear more
in the coming days if and when those
restrictions on foreign share trades on
the moscow exchange
are lifted or are altered in some way
jane
okay mark thanks very much
this is sky news today coming up as the
un announces that more than half a
million refugees have fled ukraine we'll
ask a spokesperson for the organization
what help is being offered to those who
flee
[Music]
i'm david blevins and i'm skye's senior
ireland correspondent
[Music]
i'm based in belfast a city transformed
by peace but still struggling with its
past
the two sides are as far apart as ever
and it's over that question of who has
sovereignty in northern ireland
the very issue that's been the source of
tension here for generations
it takes 60 minutes to cross the irish
sea it took the british monarchy a
century
i've spent 25 years reporting the
journey from conflict to peace
the political parties of northern
ireland have reached agreement
we help you understand the world with us
today
we have reached an agreement with the
conservative party on support for
government in parliament
we already know what the government gets
out of this deal what exactly does the
dup get out of it well 1.5 billion
pounds
welcome to winterfell it's an iconic
location in this globally acclaimed
drama
ophelia was the most powerful hurricane
this far east in the atlantic on record
you can't live in a place like this and
not appreciate the environment
[Music]
i'm greg milam skye's u.s correspondent
here in los angeles
i've seen the dark side of america
well president putin's war in ukraine is
no means universally popular back in
russia there were protests throughout
the country across the weekend and
joining us now from moscow is tikkon
ziadko the editor-in-chief of tv reign
the only independent news channel in
russia
really good to talk to you today how
easy are you finding it to report
what is happening in ukraine
uh well uh first of all uh thanks for
having me here uh no it's not easy at
all uh it's not
easy at all because the russian
government is trying to
to cut off all the information and
there are several restrictions
uh and
already several websites in moscow
were blocked by the government and a lot
of people
here in moscow the
they are afraid that uh it is just the
beginning and that the media outlets
will be shut down and it's really hard
to get information uh about
how russian off so-called operation is
going
we we're gonna we we almost don't have
any information about deaths of russian
soldiers we don't have information about
uh deaths of uh civilians uh what we
have from russian government is just two
or three
videotapes per day by the
spokesman of russian ministry of defense
and that's it
and how many people are able to see your
output in russia do you think
well i don't know exactly because we are
being broadcasted on uh several
platforms and it's uh the easiest way is
to count the number of viewers on
youtube and uh on youtube it's something
like 20 to 25 million
millions of views per day so so the the
interest and the audience now is pretty
huge
and what steps of the russian government
taken to try to
alter your content
well they uh they they released a
statement saying that
all the information
which is not official information
posted by
ministry of defense could be designated
as a fake information and
in russian law there is an article
against
fake information the media could be
blocked for posting fake information so
every minute we are
waiting whether we will receive a letter
from from state officials about
uh blog about block of our website or
not but the only way for us
not to not to get mad is not to think
about it and just go straight with our
work
are you though concerned for the safety
of your employees
of course no one knows what will happen
here in in the minutes look listen uh
five days ago uh
on wednesday
we lived in a different not the country
in a different world
i had i had plans my friends had plans i
i was going to travel somewhere etc etc
now the world unfortunately had changed
so much that we you cannot be sure in
anything and in your
security as well
are you able do you have reporters in
ukraine
able to bring you reports independently
yes we have uh one reporter on the west
of uh ukraine now in uh libya
and and you've been able to broadcast
from them pretty successfully
yes i i just saw her
her uh
her story from from there on air yeah
and what about the protests that we've
seen inside moscow the images that we've
had from moscow today aside from the
images of of president putin have been
images of of cues for people uh trying
to get money out of cash machines and
also over the past few days we've seen
some images of protesters uh concerned
about the war who are being taken away
by the authorities is that very much
what is happening on the street
well if you compare the situation now
and this situation in 2014
when uh there was an annexation of
crimea these two situations are
completely different in 2014
there really was huge support among
russian population now we don't we don't
know uh because
as as in every authoritarian state it's
hard to have a sociology here in russia
but i am pretty sure that this war is
not supported as much as
uh
annexation of crimea was supported but
at the same time
you have to understand that the
society in russia is depressed
last year was really hard for
russian civil society for a russian
independent uh society um
the leader of opposition alexey navalny
is in jail all his structures are
destroyed some of his
supporters
in in jail or they were forced to leave
the country
they um
[Music]
over last year they designated as
foreign agents a lot of media outlets
and
independent journalists they
closed a lot of ngos for example just
today one of the main russian angel
memorial was uh was destroyed by by the
court so these
people are depressed people are afraid
of going out in the streets that's why
uh there is not a lot of people out
there but still
people people are ready to protest
because they
i think not the majority of them support
this this
uh crazy war
well it's astonishing to see those
images of people risking their lives
going out there and and protesting at
tikan ziad ko from tv reign thank you so
much for talking to us today
thanks for having me thank you
well the united nations refugee agency
says now that more than half a million
people have crossed into neighbouring
countries from ukraine
matthew saltmarsh joins me now from
geneva he's a spokesperson for the
agency
and just give us the latest if you could
matthew on on the figures are the
majority of those coming across the
border into poland
that's right as you mentioned the latest
figures that we have are for about half
a million although we would stress that
those figures have been rising
hour by hour and day by day so we can
expect those to keep rising throughout
the course of the day
the majority of those have gone into
poland although of course there are
significant numbers that have gone to
moldova to romania to hungary and to
slovakia as well
and what facilities are available for
these people as they cross these borders
well as as you've been hearing there's
obviously a lot of congestion and it's
very difficult to get across the borders
so the people arriving
are exhausted many of them have traveled
for
many hours if not days to get there
when they get over there obviously it
depends country by country and it is
those countries in europe that are
leading this response we the unhcr and
our un partners are supporting them and
we're ready to help more if needed
but i think you're talking in the first
instance about basic reception so
putting people up giving them a roof
over their heads making sure they've got
food warm clothes because of course it's
cold
water and medical attention if it's
needed just it's you're talking about
the very basics at this stage
and are there issues with those without
ukrainian passports when they when they
get across the border
well we've seen some reports of there
being difficulties getting across the
border and of course we would urge that
anyone who has protection needs anyone
who needs that safety should be allowed
across the border
but we haven't heard uh yet of there
being problems with people who have got
across the board already
um what can governments do what are you
hoping that european governments will do
now because of course the numbers are
going up all the time this could be an
extraordinary number of people couldn't
it
it could be i mean we within the u.n uh
uh are forecasting maybe or expecting or
planning for i would say uh four million
the eu has said that figure could be
higher
so the eu is now currently talking about
that and and they're considering whether
to give some kind of longer term status
to those who arrive
uh from the ukraine um we would welcome
that of course because it it makes the
management of the situation
much easier
but i think in the longer term of course
there are questions of reception of
where people go of which countries they
go to
and so far those questions haven't been
broached because it's very early still
in this crisis
well that is the key isn't it because
because
helping those people for for 24 48 hours
is one thing but
settling four million people around the
whole of europe is entirely different
isn't it
that's right and that's a question we
know that the eu are looking at this
week but in terms of us and the un we
will be putting out ourselves an appeal
with our partners
in the next couple of days and this will
focus
inside the ukraine where as you know
access is very difficult at the moment
but also outside the country in the
neighboring countries and this will be
an appeal to the international community
for financial support
to to help those refugees and those who
are displaced within the country as well
does it make a difference that that for
many of these people coming across they
are leaving and they hope it is only a
temporary leave does that change the way
that they are are treated in any way
it's very hard to answer that question i
mean people leave because they have to
leave and i think many of them leave of
course hoping dearly
that it will be a very short stay
it's really impossible to answer that
question at this stage because so much
depends on the nature of the war whether
as we hope there will be some form of
peace negotiations and the guns can fall
silent
but unfortunately in many refugee crises
around the world they do become
protracted
and people don't often go back as
quickly as they want to obviously we all
hope that there can be a solution and
that people can go back soon
but often that's not the case
unfortunately
yeah indeed
really interesting to talk to you
matthew saltmarsh uh spokesperson for
the uk for the un high commissioner for
refugees uh thank you very much for
joining us thank you
uh let's just take you across to kiev
where the ukrainian foreign minister
dimitro kuleba has been speaking in the
last few minutes
about ukraine
expectation of the war the whole world
all of the ukrainians heard that
president putin is
denying us the right to existence
in the same way as the nazis did not
give
the jews the right to existence
president putin does not
offer
the ukrainians to coexist with his
identity with his state
that's why we will not surrender
we understand that for us this is a
matter of survival
whether it's
reznikovs zalozne coleba or the
president's opinion it's not about the
surname
it's about
this war been our war for existence
we are receiving humanitarian help and
political help not just from the western
countries but from some
gulf countries it's not just the gulf
but asian countries
that help is getting through to us
it is true
that the countries of those regions
are not currently helping us with arms
that we need to fight the aggressor they
are finding other ways to help us
and we are very grateful to them for it
and the myth that is also
forced upon you that the u.s
and
anyone else in the nato block do not
need ukraine it's also a lie they are
with us now look in the number of
countries who have joined and supported
and are supporting the resolution of the
un general assembly it's not just the us
it's not just the nato countries it's
not just the west there are many
countries from around the world each of
them
is finding a way to support ukraine
and we're grateful to them
a question from a latin russian speaker
edition
the volume is low well this is crazy the
question was about nuclear weapons that
is
crazy
that will bring the world into
catastrophe
if
what president putin is doing now the
war he started is the attack on the
global order then the use of nuclear
weapons will become an attack
against the humanity
altogether so we have to prevent it at
any cost
well that there the ukrainian foreign
minister um speaking obviously
translated there comparing president
putin to a nazi in terms of his denial
of ukraine's right to exist and
stressing that in his words we will not
surrender uh that the us is with us now
and is also pointing out that they've
received humanitarian support from some
gulf and asian countries although they
haven't helped with arms he says they've
been able to help us in other ways
let's go look at the weather
[Music]
look forward to brighter skies
the weather
sponsored by qatar airways
england and wales will see prolonged
rain today while the windy northwest
will have sunshine and showers it'll be
quite mild there'll be a chilly breeze
and coastal gales in the northwest
southeast england will stay mainly dry
through the second half of the afternoon
for the rest of england wales and
southeast scotland can expect prolonged
rain for a time
scotland and northern england will see
the rain giving way to a scattering of
showers later elsewhere there'll be a
mix of sunshine and showers but the
showers will become increasingly
confined to northern scotland
rain over england and wales will mostly
clear overnight but drizzly outbreaks
will linger over southeast england
elsewhere there'll be just a few showers
for northern scotland it'll be mild in
the south quite frosty elsewhere with
the odd fog patch possible
tuesday will be mostly fine but southern
england will be dull and drizzly while
the southwest will see heavier rain
moving in later northern scotland can
expect some wintry showers it's going to
be mild but cooler than today
weather
sponsored by qatar airways
you're watching sky news coming up we'll
have the very latest live as
negotiations begin despite reports
dozens have been killed in a rocket
attack in the city of kharkiv
[Music]
so
[Music]
this
oh
[Music]
you